what's going on guys
the 88th annual Academy Awards are right
around the corner or as they're also
known the Caucasian Jubilee Awards you
know all the nominees they're household
names but today we'd like to shine a
spotlight on some lesser-known works and
a few things they'd like to delete from
their IMDB page so join us in people
they were famous
Oscar Titian Mark Ruffalo is nominated
for Best Supporting Actor for his work
in spotlight but before he was an
investigative journalist blowing open
clergy sex scandals he was getting
stabbed and murdering demons in Mirror
Mirror - Raven dance never heard of it
join the club
wait was that a terrible low-budget
horror film or the original origin story
for The Incredible Hulk
okay I gotta be honest I'd love it if
the first MCU film was revealed to be
Mirror Mirror - Raven dance take that
Iron Man boom also nominated for
spotlight is the lovely and talented
Rachel McAdams but she got her start
fighting another social menace that
plagues young people around the world
believe me ax in this very special
episode of the Disney Channel Original
Series famous Jett Jackson you were
going in there to make yourself throw up
what no because I've been around enough
actresses who've had that habit I know
the signs okay fine I do this once in a
while but it's no big deal no big deal
and you're making yourself sick don't
you know you're doing to your body I
know exactly what I'm doing
whoa it is so refreshing to see one of
our most talented young actresses taking
on such an important issue it's good to
see bulimia really put into the
spotlight scripted there that's the name
of the other movie then we're firing our
writers Sylvester Stallone is up for
Oscar gold in his seventh go-around as
Rocky Balboa in the film Creed but way
back when even before the first rocky
and after he was in a porno called the
Italian stallion he was a tough guy in a
leather jacket scaring a nebbishy Woody
Allen in bananas
even though he's now a respected
oscar-nominated actor
there are many critics who would still
say sylvester stallone should have stuck
to non-speaking roles well you can suck
it haters
I hope Stallone wins his Oscar and
sticks it on an arrow and shoots it at
you Rambo style boom take that YouTube
commenters I mean movie critics haters
right guys
Kate Winslet is nominated for I think
her 47th Oscar but even before she had
to corral a manic Steve Jobs at various
product launches she was just a wee lass
on this BBC sci-fi teen show dark season
how do you do
hey dude where's Marcy late muscles
always 2 minutes 30 seconds Leslie
Robert Coles has gone run about here
today which Robert calls Robert Coles
with no Channel Robert Coles with nasty
shoes Kate Winslet lovely woman
beautiful alabaster skin but if I may
say so a little bit of a late bloomer
and takes one to know one
I am still hoping to bloom Kate's
Titanic co-star Leo DiCaprio is an Oscar
frontrunner for his role in the revenant
but before he braved the outdoors he
braved the outsiders in this Fox TV
pilot based on the hit film directed by
Francis Ford Coppola do not blink or you
will miss leo in this clip
when you hood stop young actors here's
your career path Leo has laid it out for
you
you start off fighting girls then you
fight critters then you fight the ocean
then you fight dreams then you fight a
bear and boom you will not win an Oscar
also nominated for best actor is
everyone's favorite TV dad slash drug
lord
Bryan Cranston he's nominated for Trumbo
as a writer struggling with Hollywood's
blacklist in the 1950s but way back in
1982 he was a man struggling with his
very own sexuality and one of the
weirdest shows I've ever seen crisis
counselor do you want to continue to
live your the gay side of your life as
well or is there some one person in your
life there is and he fulfills needs that
are that I obviously can't
well don't so you get to sexuality
secret from his wife he kept the meth
secret from Skyler he kept one of his
sons in the middle for years I'm sorry
but Cranston is a crappy husband on film
not in real life I just want to make
that clear because I don't know the
difference between fiction and reality
and I'm still scared of Bryan Cranston
from Breaking Bad what's real and isn't
I don't know Jennifer Lawrence aka j-law
snagged her annual Oscar nomination for
her latest effort with BFF David
O'Russell joy but she was unrecognizable
in this early role on the USA original
monk literally you couldn't see her face
honey right Jen what's the score it's
all tied up
Oh even though that roll was brief and
mostly done wearing a mascot head
Jennifer Lawrence went on to win an Emmy
a Golden Globe a Tony and a TV BAFTA for
that performance also any time I think
of monk star Tony Shalhoub all I can
remember is his reaction to Nick Mundy
saying pain and gain was the best film
of the decade what's it like being in
the best movie in the last like ten
years like No yeah
oh well that's so great to hear oh it's
amazing
and finally we come to Batman himself
Christian Bale he's nominated for the
housing crisis film the big short
Christian Bale such a chameleon you see
the machinist he lost like 200 pounds
most people forget though that one of
his earliest roles was as a
song-and-dance man in the Disney musical
Newsies and what you gonna take to stop
the stablish can we don'twe yeah we'll
do what we gotta do until we break the
will
but this wasn't bales first on-screen
singing experience for that got to go
way back to Steven Spielberg's 1987 film
Empire of the Sun Oh Dean I'm done not
card monster done listen to him he's a
little songbird unfortunately years of
acting and the high stakes of Hollywood
have taken their toll on mr. Bale
turning that angelic voice into well
this well that was a good time what was
your favorite forgotten role from an
Oscar nominee let us know in the comment
section below
best answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rodney key hit
me up on Twitter bye-bye
he has debilitating cancer but has like
they activate his healing factor in some
continuities but that doesn't stop the
cancer just ravages his body and what
are his powers that changes - I mean
that's hands
you guys are slippery you're not giving
me at a solid answers